there we have it The Prince and Princess
of Wales volunteering here let's have a
listen in at the local Scout Hub Let's
uh and there's uh Prince George too
here engaging when they call and that
their core were dealt with on the day so
they know what is going to happen to
them
so we have been speaking about this uh
all day today haven't we how it was this
extra bank holiday
um that everyone was encouraged to help
out with local communities and there we
have it there
Prince George helping with a big power
drill there this is a local volunteer
Scout Center
cricket and this will be them helping
out showing their DIY skills and joining
volunteers
working on we understand sort of digging
new soap ways and sanding and
re-varnishing and making furniture
and Princess Charlotte too so the whole
family Prince Louis are there helping
out I'm really getting stuck in here we
know that around 6 million volunteers
are helping out across the country we
saw the Duke and Duchess of Edinburgh in
Edinburgh earlier today Princess Anne
was a cathedral but here we have the
prince and princess of Wales
volunteering and look at that
Prince Louis digging some Sands in a
wheelbarrow a mum there Princess of
Wales Catherine presumably ready to take
that somewhere useful
[Music]
to follow Henry and Jasmine and I'll
show you exactly what you're doing
foreign
[Music]
see you later
this morning
[Music]
keep going
all right
[Music]
very close
right
back
[Music]
and there you have it The Prince and
Princess of Wales taking part in the big
help out volunteering today along with
their three children